what are the rumors and the things that
we believe we know about the Stargate
movie Welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV and movie channel
[Music]
so yes I did a video there'll be a link
in the description about what we are
pretty confident we know about the
Stargate movie but there have been lots
and lots of rumors so there's a few
things that we're not so sure about and
in this video we're gonna have a chat
about him first of all we believe Mark
Fergus has actually done a script for
this movie We believe this was part of
the negotiations that happened way
before Christmas and he's actually been
developing this script for nearly six
months we believe initially this was
supposed to be a two-parter for the
series that he was working on Before
Christmas before it was decided to do a
cinematic movie and that he actually
reworked that script into this movie
idea we believe that script is basically
an sg1 Revival book what does an sg1
Revival mean we're not 100 certain but
the way I see it is two options either
they are going to get as many of the
original actors back as possible that
could be Ben prouder Michael Shanks
Amanda Tapping so on and so on
Christopher Judge whoever and actually
trying to do a straight up Revival of
the series or it just means that it'll
be an sg1 show maybe they'll bring back
a couple of the actors I hear that
Amanda Tapping and Michael Shanks I.E
um Samantha Carter and Daniel Jackson
are the two main Front Runners for that
option
um but there will be a new sg1 team so
it'll be more of a soft Revival as in
it'll very much feel like sg1 but
there'll be new characters and new sg1
team now I'm told that that's the most
likely scenario but again we don't know
that for sure I'm told that the Hope
currently is that this movie will
actually have a spring 2025 release date
now that is is a very fluid date because
basically it's going to be very
dependent on the strikes I'm told that
within 18 months of the strikes ending
they really really want this movie at
Cinemas so if the basically strikes end
before Christmas a late spring 2025 date
is what they're hoping for otherwise
it'll be 18 months after the strikes end
now I did a video basically a couple of
days ago saying the vaccity date was
more like two years
speaking to somebody that is actually
reasonably close to this end is aware of
some of the work that's already been
done they believe 18 months is actually
what Amazon are pushing for but they
also tell me that Amazon love putting
these strict timelines in place they act
like a business not a studio and
sometimes I'm told they're a little bit
naive on how long these things actually
take and that other projects that
they've put these sort of timelines on
always miss the mark So I think summer
or Autumn 2025 is more likely we believe
that the movie is actually just an
opener and that actually they are
intending to follow up with a series
almost immediately I am told that the
idea is to get basically three or four
sound stages that these will be the
Stargate sound stages and that will then
be the base for Amazon Stargate projects
moving forwards their idea is this will
become a flagship franchise by that
means it's going to be their franchise
their jewel in the crown to go up
against Star Wars Star Trek and so on
that this will be their major sci-fi
project for the next decade at least and
that they want the movie basically to be
an advert for one that follows and they
want the series to be on the screens
almost immediately after the movie hits
Cinemas we believe they have this idea
that they're going to film all of these
projects on those three or four sound
stages and that actually they're going
to be using sets amongst themselves and
actors will bounce between all of the
different projects that are going on at
once that we're going to see miniseries
longer seasons and movies straight to
cinema and straight to Prime and
actually there is already quite a loose
penciled in plan for anything up to
three series and three movies so Amazon
are really seemingly taking this very
seriously but
even though I am actually really
confident this is what has been um
thought up till now I didn't put this in
the fact video mainly because I actually
think all of these are just penciled in
they're plans that could change
dramatically there are also plans that
were changed dramatically if the movie
didn't do very well at the box office so
I'm not confident enough to say that
anything like that that these three
seasons three movies Etc are plans that
will maybe ever happen so the plan was
essentially to have these sound stages
in Canada but I told you that a few
months ago but that was based on
somebody's opinion that actually does
work there because he was aware that
Amazon were working very hard to get
several sound stages in um and around
Canada and then around Vancouver these
are going to be basically built and
owned by the Hackman group but rented to
Amazon now it's moved on a little bit
since then because others sources have
actually said they've potentially seen
some of these down stages being
constructed and very very early
preliminary work done on sets one source
has even said he's potentially saw a
Stargate being constructed and this
happened in Poland another sources said
that actually believe the CGI work was
penciled in to be done by a German
company if you know your European
geography actually Germany's Next to
Poland so that would kind of make sense
so it would look like Eastern Europe is
actually the place where Stargate might
get made now this is interesting because
actually MGM does have a really good
working relationship in Eastern Europe
it's made movies there before it has
really strong links with several
production companies in the area
companies that will actually make props
etc etc as well as CGI companies so it
does seem that Eastern Europe may be the
destination for Stargate maybe it just
seemed that the initial potential budget
for the movie 70 to 80 million dollars
now again I'm pretty confident on that
number but I think it will change
depending on what project the director
decides to take it in so again I'm not
sure that that number is going to stay
at that level I think it might increase
slightly and I believe again speaking to
people who are sharing their opinion
more than what they know for fact is
that Amazon's plan is to have quite a
low budget initial movie now 70-30
million dollars is still a decent budget
don't get me wrong but they're not going
in the 200 250 million dollar area like
a lot of movies we've seen recently have
been aimed at
they are going for a more modest budget
and they are expecting a more modest
return that may be because they are
going to be focusing the movie for
Gators and by that I mean this is not
going to be a film that they're thinking
about maybe bringing in lots of new fans
it's a movie that they're planning to
aim for Stargate fans already if more
people come to watch you think great but
the idea is to really excite Stargate
fans and get them to the cinema now that
does mean that your potential pool of
audience is slightly limited it's based
around only people that already love the
franchise instead of hoping to bring in
more but
Amazon Executives believe that is the
best way to go if they want to get the
Gators on board and that is something
that they're really Keen to do and they
look at things like what happened with
Picard season three and think yes there
is an audience there for something if
they pitch it at the right level and
they picture two Stargate fans so we
could actually get to see something that
us Gators are really desperate to see
now that again depends on whether the
director decides to go in that direction
because the director is going to have a
lot of influence on what the final
project looks like
but that does seem to at least be
currently Amazon's intention one big
area though that we think we're
reasonably confident on but not certain
is that actually Amazon will go forward
to this without another big movie
partner big Studio partner now they were
initially looking at Sony Warner
Brothers and maybe somebody else to
actually partner with to make the movie
that is something that's happened a lot
in the last few years with Amazon
because they generally didn't own Studio
space Etc they were still a relatively
young studio and they partnered with
other Studios so that they could make
the movie there but also so they
basically leaned on their experience a
great deal
Amazon though have always had the
ambition to become a grown-up studio in
their own right and it does seem that
Stargate RoboCop Etc will be movies made
by MGM and Amazon and without another
partner and I think that is a very good
thing if that's what happens because I
do think too many cooks spoil the broth
and actually having too many production
companies too many people involved in
the project
it's just asking for trouble so let's
hope that's what happens
so Guys these are the things that we
think we know about the Amazon movie
they're the things that we believe and
I'm confident enough to tell you but I'm
not going to say a fact get into the
comments and tell me how confident are
you that these things are accurate and
that these things are true how confident
are you that this is what we're going to
get in the end or will the strikes mess
all this up and will it probably
completely change in the next six months
anyway get to the concert tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where most of our new videos appear
first and you get to see them without
the adverts and for a small contribution
each month you even get a free gift also
you can go to scitrack.co.uk where we do
articles for most of our videos where we
try to add a little bit more information
for you to consider yeah go and check it
out
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign